this one's great whoever wrote that so
good hey it's Sydney Sweeney I'm Glenn
pal and we are here to read thirst
tweets Sydney Sween distracts me I'm
sitting here doing nothing but suddenly
I have to stop doing nothing so I can
think about her booty thank you for
giving my booty some love for once it's
always my boobs true let's even it out
guys thank you good booty and focus on
it let's all think about it let's take a
second City Sweeney's
booty okay I'm good you good I'm good
Glen pal can I kiss your cheek please it
looks soft and smoochable heart is it
it's not really soft I me got some
Scruff it's like if you want to lofa
your lips you kiss my cheek soft lip
sydne and glimp pal let me breathe for a
second I think this a cry for help we
should probably get like one of those
like Life Alert buttons for this person
I've seen Sydney Sweeney and I can't get
up that's my Grandy's email I fall and I
can't get up as her email when she signs
off of an email at the bottom it's
always how I fall I can't it's kind of
awesome I know that's
hilarious when I'm old that's how I want
to sign off females drum roll my death
I'd let Sydney swey bite my head off
like a praying mantis everybody kisses
differently I guess yeah that's an
interesting visual it's kind of hot I
usually don't bring bugs into the
bedroom you know what I mean yeah but
it's a good it's a good it's a it's a
are we thinking about the same head or
Top Gun is propaganda Glen pal being
sexual wait wait what uh Top Gun is
propaganda Glen pal being sexy
propaganda sure thanks Jordan if my
mother and Sydney Sweeney were both
hanging off a cliff I would use both
arms to pull Sydney Sweeney to safety oh
my God your poor mother I would then
reach my hand down to save your mother
no the mom's dead it was it was it was a
momentary decision somebody had to live
and you lived and you're going to have
to live with that that mom felt to her
death because you're such a star that's
terrible Glen pow can act Sydney Sweeney
can act they're hot they will conquer I
think that should be our tag life I like
put that on the poster right there
Sydney Sweeney's mother do you know what
that means I I don't know what that
means what does that mean like love like
Taylor swept his mom I still don't get
it Beyonce is always mothering mothering
are you maternal or you you Mom you're
like Queen it's similar to Queen why
don't you say queen because we say
mother now still don't get it it feels
like mmy issues you know what I mean it
feels like there's some psychological
[__] we need to break down with where
the internet's going I don't know why
Sydney Sweeney is mother really you
would make a great mother but you are
not mother thanks something about Sydney
swen and Glen Powell makes me feel
bisexual as you knew that AF that meant
that right yeah I got that bisexual as
so that means they like us both so
they're just they just can't choose yeah
they want us both not at the same time
just like maybe at the same time you
never know you pervert Academy Award
winning sound of Glen pal ABS flexing in
the sun they make sound yeah it sounds
like like scooping coconut oil that's
what it sounds like it's like a yeah
whenever Jen just would put stuff all
over you we had someone on this movie
constantly just lubing us
up that's how you Lube up a romcom
straight to the theaters Sydney Sweeney
could spit on me and call me trash and
I'd thinkk her Sydney Sweeney if you see
this I'm free Sundays I don't have a lot
of Sundays free but well Sundays are not
for spitting or calling someone trash
that's the Lord's
Day most dangerous game is really just
me trying to get a good screenshot of
Glen Pal's butt not that hard not that
hard not that hard this last month has
been pretty [__] for my butt I need to
uh cover it up says my mom when I she
saw being Men's Health she said why did
you do that you've been in Hollywood too
long you need to come home and I agree
with her if I said that I wanted to
grate cheese on Glen Pal's ABS would
y'all support me he doesn't like cheese
I don't eat cheese this doesn't make any
sense s you can't do that I am a [__]
for Sydney Sweeny aren't we all let's
think about the booty
again and we're back we're just evening
it up yeah Glen pal if only you would
let me put your blank all the way down
my blank what are the blanks blank down
oh I know what it is now don't like that
let's go back to Sydney no babe I swear
I don't know who Googled Sydney skenny
boobs on my phone see there we go we're
evening it back out we're back for so
over here for the butt booty over
here I don't know what you call that
part of his abs where it looks like
Moses separating the Red Sea but I want
to lick it Glen Palace so hot OMFG again
we're bringing religion and the Bible
back into these thirst tweets and we
need to stop I am no better than a man
just a hole for
Sydney this one's great that's good just
a hole whoever wrote thaty swe it's so
good that one's going to haunt us all uh
wait now I'm confused wait it's
backwards I'm no better than a man just
a hole for Sydney Sweeney oh exactly you
get it now I know that really had a
Christopher Nolan ending to it that I
didn't expect what Glen pal I want to
breathe your nether regions I have what
oh you're talking about the spider scene
yeah she had to put her face dangerously
close to my nether regions uh for a
spider scene so Sydney Sweeney you have
breathed the air that no one else has
breathed I guess so I don't know whether
we apologize or say congratulations but
I'm a little scarred not for the faint
of go see our movie anyone but you in
December well that was interesting
pretty hot under this jacket all of a
sudden yeah what a Time guys you guys
use a lot of medical terms yeah the
mother one is still throwing me I don't
know why but I'm thrown by the hole
that's a that's a psychological issue
that the entire Twitter sphere is well
they're going to be like you're daddy am
I daddy do you want to be Daddy I could
be dad this has been fun thank you thank
you you thirsty sons of [__] that was
great
[Music]
right
yeah